Uh, when I, when I put my God,
shall we let's let's let's let's let's check out my jump right into it.
Let's jump right into it.
Let's check out mine and see you see where you guys see that.
Yeah, we.
Can, we can ignore the filth in the middle.
Honestly, in the middle. I don't it's already.
Okay. So, so, so lemme, lemme, lemme, let me spell out my three by three. Yeah.
So from, uh, top left, uh, going down, uh,
row by row. Yeah. So you've got your name. Barno fate,
zero Yvonne Galyon or emo log horizon,
one piece, uh,
he or the disappearance and black little does scream.
Someone had gone to anime and the tooth.
Jesus Christ.
[inaudible] not gonna lie. I'm not gonna lie.
I was not expecting black lagoon to be there.
I can see it really. Okay. So there's nothing like it.
I've never heard anything about black women coming from craftsmen. No,
it's great. I'm just curious.
Zone's review on it.
It's it's Brit.
It's one of the shows that I haven't had too much of a chance to talk about,
but like before, before I get into that, let me, let me, let me,
let me tell you the thought process that I.
Right.
Let me tell you this much emotion.
Let me tell you the thought process I put into like picking Scott, because I,
I, you know, at, at the beginning I was like, how the do I pick my favorites?
Cause I have like too many favorites I can talk about. Right. So then,
so then I thought, okay, here's his, here's a big thing.
What if I just pick the anime that I have rewatched? Okay.
Because if, if I've rewatched something and this is like rewatching,
not for my job, but rewatching for my own enjoyment,
if I've rewatched something,
that means there is something special about that show that has stuck with me,
that I felt like I've wanted to go out of my way to re-experience that.
I agree with that. Even, even on some shows that I think is great.
Like for example, like stuff like monster or like Kylie critical, he came,
claimed shows you don't want to rewatch. Exactly.
I feel like it's had this time in the sun,
but in terms of like what I truly like enjoyed to the core,
I wouldn't go out my eye at the moment. I wouldn't go out and rewatch monster,
you know, I, I wouldn't do that. Okay. Hold on. But I get that right.
Like I'm looking at this right now being like yeah. Rewatch that rewatch that.
Yeah. Would you rewatch one piece rewatched, one piece.
Is it even possible to rebuild it? Okay. Okay. Okay.
Here's the thing I've got to get a time machine or some I've watched one piece
or basically up to, up to the time,
skip all the way once and then I've rewatched it again once. Uh,
and then I've rewatched. Some of my favorite marks. The time I have 600,
I know it is.
And this was back when I have time to watch anime.
And I would just like, whenever I got, whenever I, you really watch, right?
I thought you were talking about like, Oh,
I've rewatched the water seven article that I rewatched alabaster.
I didn't think.
You really shown your age. You need years to rewatch that one thing.
The one that year older than me, like, me.
I love that you compensate. It'd be like, no, no. Only up until the PR,
but all the time, if I'm like.
It's still like $400.
This is why like I was having trouble putting a show in a non,
because I'm just like, is there any shown him that I actually truly love that?
I would think that I would go back anytime,
because I was going to put you Hawk show. And I was thinking.
Seven deadly sins. I'll come here. [inaudible].
But like one piece to me will go down when it finishes,
we'll go down as well.
It already is one of the greatest anime slash manga series course.
But to me when I think back and I think back because one piece isn't the perfect
show, right? I've rewatched one piece. So like claim it is like everyone,
everyone forgets about the lows of one piece where everyone forgets about the
Skylar. And I wasn't a fan of the Foxy arc,
which was a filler cannon arc that everyone doesn't talk about.
You know what I mean? These things are so fun.
Dresses. Rosa was, was like, um, it was too long. It was dragged out to,
but nothing in my opinion can touch the highs of one piece
when, when one piece is at its best. Right? Yeah. I,
I think it is the greatest, the greatest thing. You can find an anime.
I will stand by and say, even though I've watched every MITRE, June enemy,
I've cried more times watching one piece than any other.
That many episodes you saw something's going to hit. Right? Like, me.
Was that I wasn't expecting. I mean,
like there's plenty of shows that have a lot of episodes and haven't had the
highs, the one piece house.
Sam man has some
[inaudible] has some pretty high highs, man.
What I find amazing about one piece is this it's been going on for like what,
20 years now? Almost 30 now, almost like, I can't remember when it started.
I think it started in 96, 98 or 96 or something. Something like that. Yeah.
But I remember I've,
I've just caught up with the Mongo with like what the one at arc,
which is now one of the longest socks. It's so long. They,
it has three parts and it still has moments that make me feel
magical. This is like one piece is like,
like I watched some of the best moments in one piece and I get reminded,
this is why a love animate. This is why I love love Mongo.
This is why I love this medium. I'm the author of one piece I intend.
For it to be as long as it is where you're just like, it just popularized.
I,
I think he had planned because the thing about one piece is that it's this long.
And yet there are there's foreshadowing that that's happened.
Like hundreds of chapters. He's not from this planet. That is, that is,
that is being explored now. Right.
And I think he didn't expect it to be this long, but he,
but when he got popular,
he realized he can explore basically every idea here that he wanted people.
A lot of people, I feel kind of undermined odor just because it's like, Oh,
he made one piece, but whatever it's so long, blah, blah, blah.
But I think people, when you look deep into it,
people really undermine his skill for storytelling because yeah,
let's be honest. You have to be to keep people captivated. Yeah. He's,
he's been, he's been number one on Sean and John for the past, like 15 years.
Yeah.
Yeah. You don't do that by law. [inaudible].
Yeah. And like,
what I find amazing is it's been going on this long and it's not one, not it's,
it's not only got still got amazing moments in it.
Even when some of the greatest, uh,
in some of the latest chapters and some of the latest moments, but to,
no matter how far you go into one piece, you feel like there's still an upswing.
You still, you still feel like he hasn't peaked yet. And like,
how would you write a story?
That's like almost almost a thousand chapters long. And you still think, man,
there's an upswing coming. It's insane. Every time a new arc started.
Yeah. And I would keep up to date with what the mongers were saying.
Everyone would be like, how is it that the next arc is even better?
How does it keep getting better? I thought this was the peak.
And then it just keeps getting the hot dog stand Ark, keep.
Blown me away.
How does the water park adventure Supreme are keep blowing me away.
The names don't make sense. It is literally.
Prosey D video where he talks about anime arc names and like any one piece fan
who's watched that video knows that he's just calling out one piece fans there
because we will literally talking about this video before the podcast started.
And we were just mean, we enjoy, we was just talking about the big Mark.
It's funny. I was just like, Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, wait,
that's a real serious. So they were joking.
She was like big momma's house or something.
I thought it was just a shirt like that.
Right? Like when I,
when I remember when I've watched the alabaster rock in one piece, I was like,
this is the greatest thing ever made. And then water seven came out. I was like,
how is that?
How was it getting better? [inaudible] I hate to rush you guys,
but you have nine animated talk.
I can talk about one piece of the sunglasses because frankly,
I don't really want to hear your opinions. I honestly do not care.
I already know you.
Well, I already know your opinions on your name.
I already have names on feed back in there is like saying I like coming
back and I was like, I like sex. Of course. It's fun. It's just fun.
And then we've, we've gushed over. Haringey obviously right.
Like Cal disappearance is amazing.
Okay. I'm very, I'm excited to see that. Cause.
I was thinking back to, because obviously I'm the East iron man. Right.
And I was thinking like,
log of horizon is the ISA Kaia come back to because it's the only East archive
rewatched out of everything. Like zero.
I watched because it was my job. You know what I mean? I, I, that,
that was literally the only reason I,
what for zero look at Ryzen is the only ISA I've come back to be like, man,
that was, there was some good moments in this.
And I really want to re-experience some of these ideas that she's in threes out,
I'm probably going to rewatch it. Now it's out this season.
So I'm probably going to read like lock rises the only like pure ISA Chi
right now that I can like recommend without it's got no catch.
Like it's not like zero where it's like, Oh, it's, it's a time loop catch.
You know? That's, that's the interesting thing about it. Look horizon.
It's just, Hey guys, Hey guys, there's a gimmick walk horizon.
It's just an e-cig guy. That is just a good ISA guy. I actually, I agree.
I agree. It deserves to be, it has its place there.
I just can't get over the fact that you aren't ironically like Auriemma. Okay.
I just like, for the longest time, I'm like, what is it a about?
I thought it was like the child blessed. Yeah. That's it right?
It's it's not about insect. It is about incest just happens in it.
It's not about
[inaudible] difference between the two it's about incest and Bisco getting
cocked. That's what that show's about. There's incest in it. Like it's like,
like, like a center of a flavor.
Like you can't just drop that in there and be like, Oh,
there's also incessantly. Like what, what do you mean?
Because it's just a small thing insists to you. It is something. Okay. So
let me defend in incest 4k edition. I'm I'm, I'm a, I'm a do it, man.
I'm a dude. I don't care if this like, watch this clips, get, watch this clip,
get me canceled in like four years or like four years.
Watch this clip in 40 minutes, give a counselor like one month.
You know what I mean?
Everyone forgets that Orrin Mo was a legitimately good show.
When it first aired, I'm going to have to stop you. Right. There was a,
I'm going to have to show it right there.
Like everyone thinks I put Auriemma on the same level of something like Aaron
Monga sensei, no Aramark.
Since they was trashed from episode one and it knew it was trash and it's
every Monga sensor is what happens when you take all the trashiest parts of
Oromo and put that and put that into a show. Oromo was a nice,
wholesome look at otaku culture and with incest.
And the thing is the thing is the thing is when it was airing,
everyone was just like, Oh yeah, this is,
this is a parody of all like the incest lighten levels and everything like that.
Right? This is, this is just, this is just
[inaudible] everyone thought that he was just taking the out of like, you know,
this, the little girl Emoto craze happening in anatomy and lineup.
And if, if you, if you don't watch the final three episodes,
you can watch the entire series of series of Oromo and just think that, um,
and then the final three episodes happened and it, yeah, that, uh, that,
that sparked an outcry cried. It it's it's sparked an outcry. Right?
It's it's uh, it definitely, uh, because th th the reason,
the reason it sparked an outcry was because no one was actually expecting it.
It went from like 20% incest to 99%.
It was a hundred percent. There was, there was no,
there was no percentage that could be shaved off.
It went full in CESO and it was unapologetic. Admit that it would fall inside.
It's in your top nine enemy, because the reason it's okay,
I have rewatched it because it is, we watched it. Yeah. I,
I I've already said I've rewatched everything on this list.
I don't even want to see, because this, this show,
like this show is the epitome of everything I love about trashy,
Hara, manga, and anime. It's when you say that, it just sounds like satire.
It sounds like sad is not. Okay.
So remember when you went through my enemy list, I gave eeky Towson a two.
So like back when I was a teenager, I was just like, you couldn't incest. Yo,
yo, I'm, I'm, I'm better than this fan service.
I'm better than this trash anime. Um, I got good taste.
This is the show that changed all that. When I was just like,
why am I enjoying this so much?
Why do I like this filth trash show? I mean, look, I mean, look,
I mean, look, I look, shows like that. Yeah.
She assists being a perfect example.
I didn't put it in my three by three of them. Yeah.
This is really putting incest top nine middle.
I will that. That was a legitimate, deliberate choice.
I put it in the middle. Cause I'm just like, this is this show.
This show has probably had the biggest overall things or my taste
in modern anime.
You literally man email out to be like the free space and a bingo card.
I did it. And because it is, yeah, it is, is a trash.
The me right in there. There are trashy moments in there,
but I think I will defend the point that my wasn't complete trash. There,
there was some legitimately good heartwarming moments in there and it wasn't
complete. It wasn't all trash. Okay. It wasn't, it wasn't a remortgage.
It really was. It wasn't very long. You're going to jail.
Aira Munga sensei is aura, EMA rescan. That's all it is.
And you have to admit to that. No, I don't.
You have to remember every Monga sensei is the trashiest possible Oromo
concentrated. It is. It is dense orange
[inaudible] she was 12. You're honest. You're on it. Ladies and gentlemen,
this man has the largest animate YouTube channel on the platform. He said,
this is what he said. I'm I'm proud of this. I put it.
I literally put this stuff front and center. I regret nothing.
I regret nothing. That is all my computer now.
And I can't wait to use it as blackmail.